hey guys in this video we're gonna talk
about how to trigger or stimulate
something called the vagus nerve now
what does the vagus nerve it's one of
the longest nerves in the body it
originates from the brainstem on both
sides okay and it goes throughout the
whole thorax or the the the chest and
the abdomen intervening the heart the
digestive organs the spleen and it has a
two-way street
in other words information can be picked
up from the digestion and sent back up
to the brain and an information from the
brain can be sent down there so if
there's something going on digestive
lies down here it can really affect you
up here okay that's probably why you
know if you are bloated or you feel
constipated you just don't feel right
your your your brain fog you have a
headache things like that so the vagus
nerve is part of something called the
parasympathetic nervous system now the
parasympathetic nervous system is
responsible for rest and digest
so digestion rest recovery things like
that and then you have the sympathetic
nervous system which is flight-or-fight
picture being chased by a tiger running
away you need high pulse rate you need
blood flow to your muscles adrenalin
then when you sleep you need the
parasympathetic so you need both of
these working in harmony
now the problem most people is that
they're very heavy on the sympathetic
nervous system because of stress and
very weak on the parasympathetic nervous
system now if you can picture this let's
say for example you run up a stairs
right and your pulse rate goes up as
soon as you get to the top and you stop
running up the stairs the
parasympathetic nervous system kicks in
and is activated and it's you can kind
of a picture it like a wave it's like a
push down wave that it's pushing
actively your pulse rate down
so after exercise the parasympathetic
nervous system kicks in there and is the
recovery mechanism so if you have poor
recovery you really have a weakened
parasympathetic nervous system some of
them has a really good recovery they can
bounce back quick they have a very
strong parasympathetic nervous system
but a problem with this system can
really affect your not just recovery but
your ability to sleep heal it can create
all sorts of
problems in the digestive system and
fortunately certain drug companies are
starting to develop something called
electro suit achill devices for example
here's one the vagus nerve stimulation
which they basically put a little device
on your chest and they stimulate through
little mini shocks the vagus nerve to
help people with migraines headaches
fibromyalgia inflammation Crohn's
depression epilepsy and the list goes on
and on but that's pretty invasive and
there's side effects and the
effectiveness isn't that great so I'm
going to show you four things that you
can do to strengthen the vagus nerve and
really the parasympathetic nervous
system okay number one simple breathing
you can control your own breathing okay
consciously and affect the
parasympathetic nervous system because
when you're in a stress mode your
breathing is altered usually it's like
you're breathing in slowly but you're
breathing out very shallow so the
breathe the exhalation is very shallow
so it's like like that when you're
stressed so if you're trying to sleep at
night for example and you can't sleep or
you want to just calm your nervous
system down this is what you would do
you would slowly breathe in for four to
five seconds and then slowly breathe out
for four to five seconds so right before
bed you're you're just doing this you're
like
you're breathing in and then you're
having your exhalation is exactly the
same is your inhalation at about four to
five seconds okay that over a period of
a few minutes is going to calm down the
nervous system and you're gonna probably
fall asleep pretty quick so this is a
great technique right here okay number
two long walks calm the nervous system
down it's low stress a lot of oxygen
will stimulate the parasympathetic
number three there are certain minerals
that also support the parasympathetic
nervous system and the big one is
potassium because it's a calming mineral
magnesium and sodium so just make sure
your diet includes enough of these
minerals and in the ketogenic plan it's
built around supplying these minerals
right here and including some sea salt
as well on the flipside if you look at
the sympathetic nervous system you need
phosphorous okay and also calcium so
phosphorus you would get from animal
meats so if you're consuming too much
protein for example not enough vegetable
you can that alone can stimulate the
sympathetic nervous system so we want a
balance of a good amount of vegetables
to provide the potassium in magnesium
and some meats to help balance that out
and lastly there's techniques
acupressure techniques that you can do
to greatly improve the parasympathetic
recovery and also kind of turn off your
sympathetic nervous system I put a link
down below if you haven't seen this but
I did a whole webinar it's called a
stress webinar and actually walk you
through how to do this step by step all
right so go ahead and apply this and I
will see you in the next video
so if you don't have this book you might
want to check it out it's entitled it's
not lose weight to get healthy it's get
healthy to lose the weight healthy
ketosis and in a minute fasting check it
out I put a link down below